the statistics for the bite
administration are just egregious so in
about the middle of last week you
started to see the body administration
trot out a new line of propaganda their
new line of propaganda is that the
economy is actually going swimmingly
this is because the unemployment rates
are low well the unemployment rates are
low for a couple of reasons one people
have a lot of money in their bank
account because the government literally
just helicoptered cash to people last
year they just threw money at people and
so people actually have a lot of money
in their savings accounts right now that
is starting to dwindle as the
unemployment benefits have run and
you're starting to see people go back
into the workforce but this has created
a massive artificial shortage of labor
and because democrats keep pushing to
restructure the relationship between the
individual and the government there are
a lot of people who are sort of waiting
around thinking that the government is
going to pick up their tabs at this
point okay so that is problem number one
but the government is treating that as
solution because the unemployment rate
is low also there's a vast gap in the
unemployment rate between some of the
blue states and a lot of the red states
in fact all of the states that are best
on unemployment right now are red states
all of the states that are worst on
unemployment are blue states that's
because the blue states continue to lock
down over cobit because they've decided
to panic their citizens with the promise
that government would be able to solve
this crisis when in fact government
really cannot solve the crisis beyond
making the vaccines available which they
did almost a year ago at this point all
the way back in february and march okay
so the biden administration is facing
down a lot of bad news the polling data
for them is really really bad so they
started to put out this no this line
that the econo actually you don't know
what's going on guys you don't know
what's going on secretly the economy is
really really good there's only one
problem the economy is not really really
good inflation should not be spiraling
out of control this way according to the
washington post prices rose at the
fastest pace in nearly 40 years last
month 40 years increasing 6.8 over the
same period a year ago as inflation
continues to squeeze households and
businesses nationwide and complicates
the political environment for congress
and the white house that's one way of
saying that democrats are in serious
trouble according to the generic ballot
republicans are up 10 points in the
generic ballot right now and those
numbers rarely go the other way when the
when the party in power is already
trailing in the mid-year elections in
the midterm elections
by the end of december of the year
before it almost never goes the other
way
there are very few exceptions to that
particular rule 2002 is one of those
rules and that's because of september
11th but generally the party in power
doesn't do well in the midterms and if
they're trailing it usually gets worse
for them before the election
consumer price index data released
friday by the bureau of labor statistics
showed that prices rose 0.8 in november
compared with october with inflation
spreading further throughout the economy
including to areas that had not been as
affected by the coronavirus pandemic the
november data marked the largest
12-month increase since june 1982 during
a period when inflation was more of a
scourge on daily life than most
millennials have ever known current
inflation dynamics have been spurred by
a devastating pandemic that royal global
economy upsetting the workforce and
supply chains et cetera et cetera et
cetera okay well actually if you were to
measure inflation by the same sort of
consumer price index that we used in
1980 the inflation year over year in the
united states is not 6.8 percent it's
like 14 percent okay this is
devastatingly bad and even the media
have been forced to cover it so here is
for example abc news is david muir
saying yeah i we already know inflation
is high
you don't need us to tell you what
you're seeing already the new report out
tonight showing inflation is now near a
40-year high in this country consumer
prices up 0.8 percent last month alone
year-to-year prices up now 6.8 percent
americans are paying more for gas food
clothing and cars tonight president
biden acknowledging it is squeezing many
families across this country he pointed
to the pandemic the supply issues not
just in the us but around the world but
we know there are many moving parts on
this
okay and again it's not just david muir
abc's rebecca jarvis says this is not a
bump in the road but for all the talk
about the abiding administration saying
that this is merely temporary this ain't
temporary
most economists do see these prices as
more than a bump in the road they expect
inflation to persist through next spring
and remember these supply chain issues
are global caused by the pandemic but
there are also as you point to labor
shortages issues of people many
americans waiting to return to work
until they see wages rise more
significantly having saved up two
trillion dollars throughout the course
of the pandemic by not dining out by not
traveling expectations are now that the
federal reserve will have to step in and
hike interest rates next year in order
to cool things up
so how much are the expenses up
according to cbs's news is nora
o'donnell expenses for the typical
family are up four
thousand dollars okay that's not a minor
bump in the road that's not a hiccup
four thousand 000 is a lot of money for
most people
prices were up 6.8 in november compared
to a year ago that is the biggest
increase in nearly 40 years the cost of
pretty much everything is surging food
gas electricity housing cars and clothes
and those who received raises this year
are seeing them wiped out by
skyrocketing costs listen to this by one
estimate expenses for a typical american
family have shot up by about four
thousand dollars in the past year
okay democrats are in real trouble here
because again all of their policies are
geared toward making this worse not
better the democrats are trying to
maintain that everything is fine and
everything is fine or they're trying to
blame the federal reserve but the
reality is that their policies are the
big problem there's an article from the
washington post yesterday it is titled
in liberty county workers who quit feel
liberated but the community discovers a
powerful downside oh you mean that
paying people to stay home leads to
price inflated inflation and shortages
who could have suspected such a thing
except for anyone with a functioning
prefrontal cortex according to the
washington post maggie towne quit her
job as a hotel front desk manager
because the pandemic taught her she
could squeeze by without her paycheck no
home with her kids talen says her life
is much improved but that at the la
quinta hotel she left an exodus of
housekeepers and front desk workers
forced owner hassel patel to close the
swimming pool and fitness center and
sharply reduce room cleaning fannie lou
bruton left her job as a cook because
she didn't want to be around so many
people anymore she realized she said i
did enough she's delighted that the
covet pandemic drove her into retirement
but at izola's country cafe where the
staff has plummeted from 42 to 12
workers the owners had to eliminate
breakfast slash their hours and shut
entirely on sundays
liberty county a 45-minute drive
southwest of savannah is quit town usa
one of the many places across the
country where the pandemic slammed the
brakes on propulsive job growth and
startling numbers of people have quit
their jobs this year including more than
12 million americans this fall alone the
result according to business owners and
county officials is a place where people
are thinking about work in new sometimes
revelatory ways but also feeling the
pain of reduced services pinch bottom
lines and a diminished sense of
community
right because it turns out that the
left-wing dream that nobody ever works
anymore and then we all get to sit home
and finger paint jackson pollock that is
not real
people actually need work to feel
fulfilled also if you wish for there to
be productive goods and services for you
to trade with somebody else you need to
go to work
the left's dream which is that everybody
will basically stay home and the
government will cut them a check while
they watch soap operas is a ridiculous
and stupid dream it undermines actual
human flourishing
workers who have stepped away from
full-time jobs say the pandemic helped
them discover they can survive on
occasional gig work and government
benefits oh what can they well who pays
for those government benefits pray tell
could that be the rest of us who are
working
work harder millions on welfare depend
on you and bring back the 1970s bumper
stickers
many liberty county residents left
minimum wage positions at restaurants
hotel and retail outlets to take jobs at
the county's burgeoning warehouses and
distribution centers the upside as much
as double the pay and more flexibility
in work hours the downside severe
strains of the mom and pop businesses
they quit and damaged or severed
long-standing social bonds
so yeah all the people who say they're
for small businesses have basically
wrecked small business across the
country there has never been a
dichotomous split in wealth like we've
seen during this pandemic probably
throughout human history
basically the middle class split into
people or at big corporations which did
pretty well during the course of the
pandemic
and welfare and if you're in the middle
if you're running a small mom-and-pop
shop if you're running a restaurant if
you took out your life savings and you
tried to build a business
and your business just wasn't large
enough to survive the government
shutdowns and guess what you're out on
your ass
and the left is celebrating this they
think this is good
they think this is good
right it is not good okay it is very bad
and by the way it has bleed over effects
in terms of the inflation rate
and now you get the inflationary spiral
because why would you re-enter the
workforce unless you get a giant raise
but if you get a giant raise guess where
the prices are going to have to go in
order to pay for that giant raise and so
you get a wage price spiral that is what
is happening right now
the biden administration is trying to
downplay this pretending that it's not
really a big deal
in fact here is the president of the
united states joe biden trying to remain
alive saying that uh you know
inflation's really not that big a deal
this is joe biden over the weekend
you know the biggest
one one of the a third of the increase
in inflation is used automobiles
um so i mean it is a real problem
but the point is that has to do with
supply chain as well but it also has to
do with the fact that not everybody's
looking for a used automobile but those
who are they're paying higher prices
because there's fewer of them because of
the cobit and what was sold out and the
like
okay so cream cream of wheat for both
mouth and brains the president of the
united states trying to downplay
inflation as used cars is insane at the
beginning used cars were driving some of
the inflation stats
not anymore what is driving the
inflation stats at this point is not
even things like food and gas okay the
consumer price index absent food and gas
numbers is still extraordinarily
inflated
everyone knows this so he's lying to you
and the thing is that not a lot of
people are believing it jen saki was
asked questions about inflation over the
weekend she didn't have much to say
about it she tried to avoid the
questions
given what jerome powell is now saying
does the administration does the
president acknowledge that inflation is
more entrenched and not transitory well
kristen i would say that
i can't speak obviously for jerome
powell but i think part of the point
here is that doesn't really matter what
you call it
oh it doesn't oh okay also chen saki
added the prices are moving in the right
direction which is weird since last
month they headed in the wrong direction
[Music]
while we've seen costs increase in some
areas and we've seen
a good direct that move in a good
direction in some areas as well
what we need to do now is think about
what we're going to do about rising
costs what is our plan to address rising
costs
and what is their plan to address rising
costs they have a two-prong plan one is
to basically kick it over to the fed and
hope that the fed tapers and then they
can blame the fed for the sinking
economy as opposed to you know their own
bad policies and two spend more money so
over the weekend joe biden said we've
never had this kind of growth in 60
years but inflation is affecting
people's lives the reason why economists
think bill back better is going to in
fact diminish the impact on inflation is
because it's reducing costs for ordinary
no it is not no it is not larry summers
who has been the voice of reason
throughout this entire inflationary
spiral you remember that he was the
treasury secretary under bill clinton
and he was saying early on when the
biden administration was pushing
a 1.9 trillion dollar quote-unquote
bailout package that was absolutely
unnecessary in the aftermath of vaccine
distribution he said we're going to hit
an inflationary spiral and everybody
laughed at him because we truly have not
had a major inflationary spiral in the
united states for 40 years well now it's
back larry summers was right all y'all
were wrong and here is larry summers
saying yeah if joe biden got his
spending plans through there would be
more inflation not less
i think the inflation rate would be
slightly higher in 2022
and 2023
with the buildback better than it would
be with without the buildback better i
think over the longer term there might
be some effects that go that go uh the
other way but i think over the next uh
couple of years the
what economists say ceteris paribus
other things equal it would raise the
inflation rate
okay he is correct okay now here's the
problem for the democrats they can't get
out of this without one of two things
happening
either joe biden stopping the spending
and allowing things to get back to
normal which they can't do because his
entire agenda is reliant on the idea
that he has to do something big and he
has to keep pushing big things or the
federal reserve has to taper and taper
in really short order and when that
happens you'll see a spike in the
unemployment rate this is what happened
back when paul volcker did this in the
early 1980s and paul volcker had
actually been appointed to the federal
reserve by jimmy carter and he waited
until the reagan administration and you
really started to raise interest rates
and when that happened you saw a sharp
spike in the unemployment rate in the
united states
because these two things tend to happen
when the federal reserve makes it more
difficult to borrow money for banks
banks start giving it out at higher
interest rates that means fewer people
borrow means less spending and that
means fewer jobs so now that you're
trapped in this cycle it's very
difficult to get out of that cycle
without some form of pain
and and that pain is coming now
presumably joe biden would like to blame
that pain you would imagine on the
federal reserve right at least he can't
blame himself oh well you know the
federal reserve they're independent
they're doing what they want they're
just doing what
okay but here's the bottom line the
american people are gonna hold him
responsible because again this is his
economy none of this was necessary it
was not necessary this is not all supply
and chain problems this is a spending
problem this is a problem by the way
that is to a certain extent bipartisan
we should not have blown seven trillion
dollars into americans pockets last year
it's something we should not have done
but at least you could excuse that by
saying there were no vaccines available
so we have to try and keep people away
from from crowded areas and whatnot
by the time the vaccines were available
they were available in january once that
started to become widely available
february march there was no excuse for
what joe biden did
how's this for a title ben shapiro show
subscriber destroys like button with
clicks and logic i'd watch that make it
happen gang